θ가 0과 π 사이이고 φ가 0과 2π 사이일 때, 이전과 정확히 같은
퇴화가 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. θ가 0 또는 π일 때 φ가 무관한 것이요. 이번에는 그걸 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
왜냐하면 그 두 경우에 sin(θ)가 0이고, 그 외에는 그렇지 않기 때문이에요. 이 공식에서
θ/2 대신 θ가 사인과 코사인 함수의 인수로 나타난다는 점을 지적할 만해요. 원래 양자 상태 벡터 버전과 달리 그런 건데,
삼각 함수 항등식을 사용했기 때문이에요. 처음 세 가지는 기본적으로 소위 배각 공식의 재배열이에요.
그래서 각도가 효과적으로 두 배가 돼요. 이제 드디어 Bloch 구 자체에 대해 이야기할 준비가 됐어요.
밀도 행렬의 식에서 항등이 아닌 Pauli 행렬의 분자에 있는 세 계수에 집중해 볼게요.
그래서 분모의 2는 무시하고,
항등 행렬도 무시해요. 그 위의 계수는 절대 바뀌지 않기 때문이에요. 그건 우리가 표현하는 어떤 행렬의 트레이스에 의해 결정되고, 밀도 행렬은 항상 트레이스가 1이에요.
이제 x, y, z로 레이블된 세 축이 소위 오른손 법칙에 따라 방향이 정해져 있다고 상상하고,
세 계수와 일치하는 좌표를 가진 점을 고려해 볼게요. 명확히 말하면, 이건 좌표가 항상 실수인
일반적인 3차원 공간이에요. x 좌표는 식 분자에서 σ_X Pauli 행렬의 계수에 해당해요.
이건 항상 실수예요. 밀도 행렬이 에르미트이기 때문이에요. y와 z에 대해서도 마찬가지예요.
이 점이 항상 단위 구 위에 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 즉, 반지름이 1인 구예요.
특히, 양의 z축이 구와 교차하는 점에서 시작해서
그게 북극이라고 생각할 수 있는 곳이에요. θ만큼 양의 x축 쪽으로 아래로 회전하고,
그 다음 양의 y축 쪽으로, 즉 동쪽으로 φ만큼 회전해서 얻는 점이에요. 이 맥락에서 θ를
극각이라고 해요. 극점에서 시작하기 때문에 기억하기 쉬워요. φ는 방위각이라고 해요.
이 두 각도는 함께 단위 구 위의 점에 대한 구면 좌표를 나타내요. 반지름을 변화시키면
3차원 공간의 임의의 점을 나타낼 수도 있지만, 여기서는 반지름이 1인 단위 구 위의 점에 집중해요.
θ를 위도라고 생각할 수도 있는데, 다만 적도에서 ±90도가 아니라 북극에서 남극까지 0도에서 180도로 가는 거예요.
그리고 φ는 경도를 나타내는데, 기본적으로 양의 x축과 교차하는 자오선을 본초자오선으로 정의해요.
그런데 저처럼 위도와 경도 중 어느 게 어느 건지 헷갈린다면, 경도는 더 긴 구간, 즉 π가 아닌 2π에 해당한다고 기억하면 도움이 돼요.
어쨌든, qubit 상태 벡터 ψ에서 이런 방식으로 좌표를 생각해서 단위 구 위에서 얻는 점은
ψ에 해당하는 양자 상태의 Bloch 구 표현이에요. 그리고 전체 3차원 단위 구를 이런 방식으로 생각하면 Bloch 구를 얻어요.
기하학적으로는 그냥 일반적인 3차원 공간의 단위 구이지만, 실제로 그게 qubit
상태의 기하학이에요. 여기에는 완벽한 일대일 대응이 있어요. qubit의 모든 순수 상태는 구 위의 고유한 점에 해당하고,
구 위의 모든 점은 전역 위상까지 고유한 qubit 상태를 나타내요. 양자 상태 벡터를 다룰 때
이 대응은 다른 이름으로도 불려요. 예를 들어 Poincaré 구라고도 해요.
하지만 양자 정보의 맥락에서는 일반적으로 Bloch 구라고 불러요. 이제 각도 φ의 퇴화를 꽤 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
왜냐하면 북극과 남극에서는 경도가 의미가 없기 때문이에요. 하지만 극점을 제외하면 지구 위의 모든 점은 위도와 경도 측면에서 고유한 좌표를 가지고, 여기서도 같은 일이 일어나요.
그래서 일반적으로 Bloch 구가 어떻게 작동하는지 설명했어요. 이제 qubit 상태의 몇 가지 특정 예시와
Bloch 구 위에서 어디에 있는지 살펴볼게요.
표준 기저부터 시작할게요. 0 상태에서는 극각 θ가 0이고, 1 상태에서는 π일 때 얻는 점이에요.
이미 이야기한 것처럼 방위각 φ가 무관한 두 경우예요. 해당하는 밀도 행렬도 Pauli 행렬의 선형
결합으로 표현할 수 있어요. 두 방법 모두 이 두 상태가 Bloch 구의 북극과 남극에 해당한다는 결론을 내려요.
0 상태는 위에, 1 상태는 아래에 있어요.
다음으로 Bloch 구 위에서 플러스와 마이너스 상태를 찾아볼게요. 다시 양자 상태 벡터나 밀도 행렬을 생각해 볼 수 있어요.
양자 상태 벡터에 대해서는 이번에 극각 θ가 π/2여야 해요. 0번째 원소가 1/√2가 되려면요.
방위각 φ는 플러스 상태의 경우 0이어야 해요. 플러스 상태에서 1번째 원소가 양수이기 때문이에요.
마이너스 상태의 경우에는 π 또는 180도여야 해요. 그 경우 1번째 원소가 음수이기 때문이에요.
따라서 이 두 점은 Bloch 구의 적도 위에 있어요. 플러스 상태는 양의 x축이 구와 교차하는 곳이고,
마이너스 상태는 반대편으로 음의 x축이 구와 교차하는 곳이에요. 해당하는 밀도 행렬의 Pauli 행렬 표현을 봐도
y와 z 좌표가 모두 0이고, x 좌표가 양수 1과 음수 1임을 알 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시는 플러스 i, 마이너스 i 기저인데, 플러스/마이너스 기저와 비슷하지만 1번째 원소에 허수 단위 i를 추가로 곱해요.
플러스 i 상태는 수업 초반에 봤고, 마이너스 i 상태는 유사한 방식으로 정의돼요.
극각 θ는 플러스/마이너스 상태와 같이 π/2이고, 이번에는 i와 -i를 얻으려면 방위각 φ를 선택해야 해요.
1과 -1 대신요. π/2와 3π/2가 그걸 만들어내는 올바른 선택이에요.
다시 한 번 이 상태들의 밀도 행렬 설명을 봐도 이전 두 예시와 꽤 유사해요. 다만 이번에는 σ_Z나 σ_X 대신 Pauli y 행렬이 있어요.
따라서 Bloch 구에서 이 두 상태는 y축이 구와 교차하는 곳에 있어요.
정리해 보면, 방금 이야기한 여섯 가지 상태가 서로 어떻게 관련되는지 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시, 사실은 예시의 클래스로, 이전과 4번 수업에서 나온 qubit 상태 벡터를 고려해 볼게요.
0번째 원소가 어떤 실수 α에 대해 cos(α)이고,